تفرج قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عن عدد من
المعتقلين من السجون الاسرائيليه اعتقلوا
داخل قطاع غزه بعد ان تعرضوا لفتره
للتعذيب و للضرب والسحل واطلق سراحهم في
حاله يرثى لها عبر معبر كرم ابو سالم هنا
جنوبي قطاع غزه ووصلوا الى مشفى الشهيد
ابو يوسف النجار هذا هو واحد من هؤلاء
الذين اعتقلوا وهو من كبار السن كما
تشاهدون كل العقاب اللي انا اخذته مقابل
اني انا قعدت في بيتي
اخذوني كسروا كتفي كتفي هذا مكسور ظهري كل
ليته
مكسر صدري من هرش رايحات منه رقبتي عملالي
فيروف بريت لانه اوريك التمزق اللي في
بدني كلي ممزع من تحت كلي ممزع نتيجه ايش
ضرب
البوات البساطير تبعت حج انت خذوك من
الشجاعيه لما اعتقك وين راحوا فيك والله
مناطق لا اعلم بها كيف و هي ما عرفتها
لانه انا مغمه من اول ما استلموني حطوا
الكلبشات في ايديا وغم عيني
بالعصابات فكانوا هم اللي
يسقوني امشي واحيانا يوقعني
بالعمد يرميني على الارض وهو بشد فيا لانه
انا مش شايف قدامي ولا شايف حاجه
شو شو سالوك شو بدهم منك بقوللك وين تين
حماس وين الانفاق وكانه انا
معاي سجل كامل لتعيين حماس والانفاق تبع
الخراي بع الانفاق معايا بدهم دلهم وين
الانفاق وقوللهم وين تبعين حماس طب انا ما
بعرف
حدا بعرف من ه اللي بدهم اياه حاجه نعم
كيف بدي لهم خذ ضرب خذ ضرب لغايه ما بدك
تقول ما بتعرف عن اهلك وين اهلك اولادك
مرك ولا انا عارف عنهم
حاجه طيبين ميتين شردين
[موسيقى]
والله اه يا
رب مشهد قاصي جدا مشهد مؤلم جدا ما بدنا
نطول كثير على الحج يعني مجرد سؤاله عن
اهله يعني اجابته كرت واضحه ما بيعرف عنهم
شيء هذا الان بوضع صحي كارثي ونحن نعتذر
عن هذا السؤال ربما الجارح لهذا الرجل لكن
كان لابد من السؤال عن مصير اسرته حتى
يعني ان كان لديه بصيص امل او معلومات هو
الان في مشفى الشيد ابو يسف النجار على
هذه الصور توصله بالعائله وان تكون
العائله بخير وان يلتقوا مع بعضهم البعض
من جديد كان الله بالعون هذه جزء من
معاناه هؤلاء الذين افرج عنهم بعد ان
تعرضوا لتعذيب واعتقال في السجون
الاسرائيليه حج كيف ظروف الاعتقال بعتكم
كيف الظروف اللي انتم اعتقلت اعتقلو فيها
ورموهم من الشحن ومن الجبات ومن الدبابات
طبوا فيهم ضرب وخبط
كسروهم بتكسروا ضلاع بتكسروا
ايديهم في واحد زره راح في عندي زلمه بقى
يحكي كويس خرفا زلمه كبير في كمان زلمه ما
انا انتقلت من ثلاث غرف اترجيت حكيت
بالعبراني بحكي عبراني ترجيت الكابتن بنت
حكت معاهم وسخت ع وعيه نقلتني مش ملاقي حب
الدوا مش ملاقي حاجه قلت لها لي اربعه
ايام باكلش انا صار معايا جفاف فيمي
نقلتني على على نقلوني على اوضه هيك برضه
كله بركسات اه فيه الله بالعون يا حاج
قديش اعتقلو ك انت المده اللي اعتقلو فيها
اعتقلوني يمكن مش عارف 40 يا 45 مش عارف
اسرتك وين عائلتك انا مش عارف صرت دشرت في
غزه ومش عارف وين هم معيش مش عارف يعني
للاسف الشديد يعني ما بدنا نطول على الحج
يعني برضه هذا الرجل لا يعلم اين اسرته
واعتقل في هذه الظروف الصعبه وهو من كبار
السن وواضع عليه الاعياء والاعتداء والضرب
والسحل وحتى يستطيع حتى بصعوبه يعني
التحدث وهو الان في وضع صحي صعب في مشفى
الشيد بصف النجار هذه الصوره التي نقلناها
لكم وجزءا من الصوره للمفرج عنهم عبر معبر
كرب ابو سالم من المعتقل في داخل قطع غزه
هاني الشاعر لقناه الجزيره مدينه
رفح